let's talk about the business of this
hardware businesses
fail at a rate at least two or three
times software businesses
because you're not only in the hardware
business you're also in the software
business
and you're not only in the software and
the hardware business you also become in
the retail
slash distribution business so you
really have to take on three
three businesses concurrently a software
business
and a hardware business and somehow
getting them to people
yeah the product is mainly sold direct
to consumer am i correct in that
direction consumer online
yeah yeah is that the only way to buy it
or can you buy yeah
uh no we haven't done any retail stores
um you know we haven't done any
like you know wholesalers or anything
like that we've you know
even not even amazon we've kept it on
auraring.com
wow and and explain to people how you do
the ring sizing
because this is a particularly um
delightful process i thought it would be
you know arduous it turns out it's
delightful yeah look i think just like
warby parker you know if you want to try
on glasses
right like you get a couple sent to your
house so what we do is if you don't know
your ring size which most people don't i
didn't know mine either
we send a you know sizing kit in the
mail when you order a ring and then you
get to pick out which size you are you
get
you know plastic set of sizes six
through 13.
figure out what size you are and then
you confirm the size and you you get a
product that you know what we hear from
customers is like
hey this feels like it's just for me um
you know it's not like i have to take
links out of the washing sizes
or so uh eight six to 13. it's really
just in terms of aesthetics you get a
little box for people who
haven't ordered one before and it just
has you know whatever the eight plastic
ones you try it on and
whichever one you want you go back
online say i'm a size 10 or whatever it
is and you get it
and then i guess you have to throw that
away it feels a little bit wasteful but
yeah or give it to a friend you know
that's oh you can give it to a friend
for
when they do it ah that's a smart idea
now
the product is not cheap 400 bucks i
think is the going price
299 to 3.99 we have a gold version and a
stealth black matte black version that
we charge 3.99 for
got it now when you get to this
level of production because you're
selling
i understand hundreds of thousands a
year now am i yeah ballpark correct
yeah um these things only cost 25 50
bucks to make so you've got
i wish you were that low really okay it
doesn't look like there's much to it so
i thought at
scale but um you you have some decent
cost of goods enough that you don't
charge a software subscription fee am i
correct
uh we don't charge a software
subscription fee that's correct you bake
into it
these things last people wear them three
four five years
we have a two year warranty which i
think the every other wearable is
basically a one year warranty by the way
yeah and then my fitbit i'm ready to
just throw it away right now after
a decade of using it because they just
break too often and now they're charging
for features and i'm like why am i
paying a subscription and buying these
off of you it's just
i know maybe i'll get the apple as well
but i wear both and i like to have two
different things and i have the eight
sleep bed
so and i'm an investor in eight sleep
which is kind of nice because you get to
get different you know versions of your
sleep from different apps and then
compare them and
it's pretty miraculous how accurate it
all is